A political crisis and now a
potential security crisis
on the streets of Israel
as the country was brought
to a standstill
by the largest general strike
in Israeli history,
sparked by Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu's
plan to weaken the Supreme Court.
And his firing
of the country's defense minister
for speaking out against the overhaul.
Fiery protests erupted Sunday
and grew Monday with demonstrators
descending on Jerusalem
from all over Israel.
Chanting for democracy
as they gathered
in mass in front of the country's
Supreme Court.
And outside Israel's parliament,
the Knesset nearby.
These changes to the judiciary
in Israel will be the most significant
since the country's founding in 1948.
Not before
they will give the Israeli
parliament, the Knesset
and therefore whatever parties
and politicians are in power
more control over the judiciary
from how and who the judges are
who are to be selected
to even the ability to overturn certain
Supreme Court decisions.
Now, critics of these reforms fear
that will destroy the independence
of the Israeli judiciary.
They would hurt, hurt
minority rights and would also hurt
human rights in Israel
from everything
from freedom of speech and expression
to freedom of religion.
On Monday, flights were halted
and Israel ports stopped work
alongside
universities, embassies,
abroad, malls and even McDonald's slim.
If the leader of Israel's largest
union demanded
the historic general strike
to stop what he called
this judicial revolution,
this craziness
it seemed to have
had the intended effect.
Zoom whatever
we are
out of the desire
to prevent a rift in the nation,
I decided to suspend the second
and third reading of the law
in this session of the Knesset
to give time to try and reach
a broad agreement.
For Netanyahu,
this may be more than just
a political setback
Critics say
the overhaul will help Netanyahu
in his ongoing corruption trial,
a charge he denies.
In a Saturday evening interview
with British journalist Piers
Morgan, Netanyahu denied
he was pushing for autocratic rule.
To try to paint me
as some Third-World
autocrat is ridiculous.
I believe in the balance.
I'm a classic Democrat with a small view.
I don't want to get into trouble
with my American friends,
but I am a classic believer
in the balance
between the three branches of government.
That's what ensures democracy.
And it's been thrown off
balance in Israel.
We have to bring it back.
Before his speech
to the nation on Monday,
he acknowledged the precarious situation
the country is in
as some right wing
groups began calling
for counter-protests, tweeting.
I call on all the demonstrators
in Jerusalem on the right
and the left to behave responsibly
and not to act violently.
We are brotherly people
with the country in chaos.
There are fears now
that this divisiveness
could still lead to bloodshed.
And while the general strike was lifted
once the suspension was announced,
that was also praised
by the US State Department.
Opposition leaders
have been a bit more circumspect
taking more of a wait and see approach,
whether there will actually
be proper
negotiations on a compromise
reform that they want to be mediated
by the Israeli president Wolf.
All right, Hadas, stay with us.
I also want to bring in
Israeli journalist Barak Ravid,
who's covering all of this very closely.
Barak.
Prime Minister
Netanyahu may be backing down for now,
but without real debate
could this crisis spiral even further
I will.
Well,
I think that
this is definitely
not the end of this crisis.
I think we're still
pretty much at the beginning
because even though Netanyahu
announced the suspension of the plan
and the opposition said
that it's ready for a dialog.
The gaps are pretty big.
And I think that
it is not an unlikely scenario
that several weeks will pass.
It will have several rounds
of negotiation,
reach a deadlock,
and then we will see
a rerun of everything
we've seen in the last few weeks.
As you know, Israelis have been out there
protesting on the streets of Israel
for months now.
How did it get to this point, Barak?
How concerned are Israelis
about an authoritarian lurch
that potentially is out there
I think that obviously
on Sunday night
when when Netanyahu decided to fire
the minister of defense, you have Garland
just because he did his job and warned
that this judicial overhaul is a clear
and immediate threat to Israel
national security.
I think this is when the penny drop,
not only for the usual suspects, people
that did not vote for Netanyahu.
I think the penny then dropped
for a lot of Likud vote And I think that
then you saw a spontaneous
rage erupt around the country,
which led to again,
hundreds of thousands of people
in the streets.
And I think that in a way, we know today
that three months
after this whole thing started,
for Netanyahu politically,
this was like hitting
the self-destruct button.
You saw the polls tonight
in three different Israeli
television channels.
All of them showed that Netanyahu is at
above.
65% unfavorability.
He never had those lowest numbers.
Hadas,
some are vowing to continue protesting
on the streets of Israel.
Where do you think things go from here?
Well, I definitely think the protests
will continue
because the protesters
now, we've seen them both
for this reform
coming out tonight,
as well as the protesters
who have been out for 12 weeks now
against reform.
They have a lot of energy.
They have a lot of organization
behind them.
And a lot of them,
I think, do not believe
Netanyahu at his word
when he says he's
going to suspend the legislation.
They're going to also want to see
whether there
will be real negotiations
over a possible compromise.
Hadas Gold and Barak Ravid, guys,
thank you very, very much.